I also the story about you that you
probably don't know before I met you I
was dating someone it was a very
unhealthy relationship anyway I don't
know if you know but I've been in a
couple of those I was probably 28 is my
guess doesn't excuse my behavior it's
still too old to baby this way it was
just a really unhealthy relationship and
you know those like toxic relationships
who were kind of in in our 20s where
everything was a thing and it was before
I understood that you can be in a
relationship with someone and it's
actually healthy for the person you're
with to be able to like say oh yeah that
girl's prettier you don't have to be you
know ridiculous about it but I know you
look at other women yeah I know that
it'd be weird to not think a pretty girl
is pretty and if you and we do it with
we do man yeah even women yeah it's
human nature and exactly why are we all
pretending that we have blinders and
it's that it doesn't have to be a sexual
thing it can also just be an
appreciation like also I feel like with
other women you know they they put in
time like notice it that's such a great
way to put it I've never thought of it
that way but this is when you were just
getting really famous and I think it was
the Vanity Fair cover maybe and and you
were on the cover and everybody was
talking about you and your body it was
just like you were having that huge sort
of like introductory moment
yeah and you were on the cover of an
affair and the guy was at the time he
just looks at me he goes see that's what
men want Oh God
that we don't that's what we want they
finally figured it out then yeah a
picture on a magazine who doesn't speak
just one photo like but she doesn't want
you yeah you know when you just get
jealous and I just was like but you're
not she's not in the running for you
like I it was this thing where I was
like but she's not available to you like
I just we've all done that like childish
immature thing but it was his way of
just saying like why his fashion only
put anorexic people and covers of
magazines for so long guys yeah into
that you know and that's what we want
and women aren't into that either like
the marketing
telling us that we're into that before
not like we want I mean I know I did I
wanted to appreciate my body and just be
as fit as I could be like no one wants
to walk in a room and feel less than
than somebody in your image that's
perfect because they're anorexic or just
naturally super thin so I think it's
important that we're all just the best
version of ourselves and we can
appreciate each other's bodies and
differences did that feel like did you
know that you were walking into being
like a body like positivity progress
icon when all that was happening no yeah
no I worked really really hard to be
super thin at the beginning of my career
because that's what you know I was a
working model and I was successful
working model and then I got these
awesome opportunities and I didn't know
that I was considered maybe I told me
girl you're fat and I was like we right
starving myself and if I'm already fat
so I had like I went on a real journey
of like finding how to appreciate my
body and my differences and what that
meant to me personally and then all I
all while being in the spotlight and
people pushing me to be the leader in
this movement because you're - instead
of a zero yeah literally I mean
literally but ya know and then but I
feel like as I was talking about it I
was also working through it and I think
that that's why it came up as authentic
as it was hmm like as I was trying to
figure out my place and how I felt about
being judged for my body realizing I
don't I don't give a shit what people
say about my body because this is my
body and taking care of it puts me in a
confident mental position to take that
stand like I know I fueled my body
properly and I worked out and I did
enjoy that chocolate and I don't really
care if you say I shouldn't have had it
because I did and I feel good about
myself
yeah I mean it's just been it's it's
been so I do think it was like
such a big it started such a big thing
yeah when I think about these
conversations that people are having and
how ad campaigns are changing and how
sizing is changing for lots of brands I
mean that is kind of when it started in
a way right yeah I mean that's how I
guess the conversation started and I
mean obviously people wanted it that's
why the conversation started it wasn't
because you know I was there it was
because people were yearning for
differences yeah and at the time I
started modeling it was you know no one
had the voice to say what they wanted
because there was no social media now
people can say no no represented this is
what I want so only designers we're
leading that charge and they were like
we want something different someone who
looks perfect but like an alien that's
literally what they would say and being
like meetings yeah they wanted the
perfect features but put together in an
alien like way like the perfect big eyes
the perfect big lips but not put
together right this is alarming
yeah a lot of people don't even know
about how why models are they this
started in during World War two I
actually weirdly wrote a paper on this
Dollard about where because I struggled
with eating stuff for so long I think I
got obsessed
yeah the origin of where this super
impossibly thin body type came from and
it came from a shortage of fabric in the
50s when world war ii happened basically
the design is really well we don't have
enough fabric so we'll just make them
smaller and smaller and it wasn't
supposed to stay like that it was just
essentially how they coped with the
shortage of fabric in the 50s Benton are
you nodding yeah thank you and and then
it just kind of stuck and that just
became the standard of beauty from just
an accident and also Marilyn Monroe was
also thin that's the other thing
she literally people are like well
Marilyn robot eat up I mean she was an
eight
she will been an eight oh yeah they were
like no even smaller they're like she's
a size 12 but the sizing was different
back then she was a 2/4 wild Ohio it
just different sizing it's like in the
UK it was similar sizing to that right
because of to here is like an ad like
that do you get sick of talking about it
about my body yeah I mean I think yes
and no I get really sick about talking
about I look like guys
and creepy ways but in this way no I can
talk about it all day because I want to
spread a positive message for other
women I think we all should own our
bodies and feel good about talking about
it in ways that we we own know and we
feel proud of but I guess I get sick of
of marketing I'm doing why are you guys
talking about it like that yeah like
come on just don't make it a thing just
hire the right person no matter their
body type or represent different people
and don't do it just as a trendy thing
do it as something that's going to stay